[Music]
[Music]
eh-eh-eh-eh
how's everybody living how you doing how
you feeling how you moving I got Warren
short the man with the stache the man
with the cash the man that'll put all
the bookies on his ass
worried sure let's go from the home of
the World Series champion Washington
Nationals Warren
[Music]
sharp how do you feel warm I'm doing
great feeling happy about the Nats I'm
not really into baseball as you know so
but I'm along for the ride my kids
however you know now that I have kids
and they're actually in school with
other kids I got a 10 year old and a 5
year old you know they're both at
elementary school now like they're this
like Nationals fever they're so they're
they're they're loving it life today so
let me this is completely unrelated and
then we'll get to football but I feel
like the analytics community looks at
the Astros as like their Lord and Savior
that because of a strobe all the way
they built their franchise and how you
know the Browns and other NFL teams have
kind of been like hey we can do that too
was this a loss for the analytics
community last night though I don't
really know I obviously have read some
of Astro ball I respect what they did
there I think it's like it's one of
those teams where okay like the New
England Patriots they believe in
analytics they seem to always get to the
championship game they might lose once
you know it is what it is but they're
obviously still a great team so I don't
necessarily think I am never a believer
that you have to win the whole thing in
order to prove that like you are the the
ultimate and then if you finish in
second rice out of you know so many
teams that oh you're just it's just a
failure so I don't necessarily buy into
that in this Oh silly me for thinking
that results equals process so I
apologize Warren before we start Laser
laser let's get in on this okay Warren
has something new for sharp school this
week we are going to get to EDS our
surprise surprise it balled out again
last week and I'm gonna impact all of my
picks this week by the way on my super
contest I went two and three one of my
losses was Tampa Bay and they got
screwed on that fumble that should have
been a touchdown it's just a trend here
if I pick a team you're getting screwed
my apologies we'll get into the biggest
strength of schedule mismatches for week
9 so you can focus on fantasy and daily
because yet again those players went off
we'll take a quick look at byes and then
focus heavily on the
aim of the week the Baltimore Ravens the
New England Patriots finally a tough
matchup for the Patriots Baltimore awful
by finally a really tough defense for
Lamar to face it is going to be
beautiful but we start off with a
concept that Warren focused on it's week
8 and as every other podcast and website
is talking about half-way MVP which is a
dumb conversation because you've been
having it for the last 7 weeks
Warren is doing a thing called win loss
over expectation and really what it is
is we look at these teams halfway
through the year and let's look back at
what we thought they were going to be
before week 1 and are they on pace to
hit their overs are they trending more
towards the under who has been exceeding
expectation and who has been really
falling flat on their face the most so
tell me how you do this what are the
main things you look at in figuring out
win-loss over expectation I look at
first and foremost we start with the
Vegas win total what was the line set
and I have to factor in juice and so I
actually don't look at the opening
number
I look at a number later in the season
after it's been bed into place a little
bit more by the sharper sharper sports
bettors and I compare what they are
doing right now from a win-loss
perspective to what they're forecasted
win-loss perspective is supposed to be
this season based on the oddsmakers to
figure out are we over expectation are
we exceeding our expectation are we
falling short because a team like the
New England Patriots their expectation
was high so should we be just going Gaga
googoo over the fact that they're doing
really well maybe not should we be maybe
propping up some of the other teams that
are really exceeding expectations even
more so than the Patriots in the same
works vice-versa and then I'm sure we're
going to talk about momentarily we also
have to take into consideration that
great equalizer which is the schedule
everybody thinks it's the NFL everybody
plays the same opponents your division
is the same you plot you play this
circular schedule of opponents but
that's not true schedules vary and
especially during the season eyes will
get
- you may have played an easy schedule
or a hard schedule you may have to face
the rest of the year and easy or hard
schedule let's take that into context as
well yeah I think actually it's funny
this year strength of schedule has been
the most talked about topic because the
two top teams record-wise in the sport
right now the only undefeated teams the
Patriots and the Niners the Patriots
have played the number one easiest
strength of schedule thus far and the
Niners have played the 10th easiest so I
think really for the first time in a
long time I'm hearing strength of
schedule talked about but Warren let's
get back factoring in all those things
Vegas strength of schedule all that who
has been the most disappointing team in
the NFL we have a lot of winless teams
out there right now who's been the most
disappointing from what you've come up
with by far it's not even close to me
it's the Atlanta Falcons you want to
talk about winless teams that's fine
obviously the Bengals obviously the
Dolphins but guess what those teams were
forecast to be bad if you want to talk
about a team that is disappointed more
than any it's the Atlanta Falcons quite
frankly I think that this could be the
beginning of the end for their head
coach he's a defensive oriented guy
their defense has not been performing we
can make excuses and injuries and all
these different things the fact of the
matter is this team was forecast to win
eight point seven games meaning eight
and a half was their win total a little
bit juiced towards the over eight point
seven games there one and seven way
below expectations and guess what
they're about to face the most difficult
schedule of opponents the rest of the
season stop what do they face before
this before this they face essentially a
league average slightly above league
average if you want to say the number
ones now yes the number thirty-two is
the toughest they've played the
fifteenth easiest schedule in the league
they're about to face number 32 the
toughest schedule most disappointing and
it's only going to get worse okay
flipside which team factoring in Vegas
strength of schedule has had the most
impressive season thus far well this is
one that I can actually take a little
bit more pride in the San Francisco 14
miners are the most impressive team in
the NFL when you factor in the schedule
of opponents that they've played as well
as their overall record against what
they were forecast to do this team was
just supposed to go eight Nate they were
four and twelve last year they were
getting back Jimmy G he was injured
coming off of ACL what's he going to do
if we saw him in the preseason I can't
tell you how many guys on Twitter were
making fun of the fact that he couldn't
complete passes and didn't look so good
they had no faith in Kyle Shanahan
literally people were calling for Powell
Shanahan's head if he didn't have a
somewhat successful season this year and
look at these guys now I couldn't buy it
I wrote in my book this team is going to
exceed expectations they were one of my
favorite teams entering the season
that's why I can take pride in their
ranking but absolutely this undefeated
team has vastly exceeded expectations so
far and while they will face a slightly
more difficult schedule the rest of the
way it's not even the top ten most
difficult schedule they have the 20th
toughest schedule in the NFL the rest of
the way and I just want to say for all
the Niners haters out there
the Patriots Bills Ravens Seahawks
Vikings Jaguars Cowboys Titans and
Chargers have all had easier schedules
thus far than the Niners so as you go
out there and you circle all the easy
wins on the Niners schedule just
remember that like I don't know five
other teams that are currently in the
playoffs have had an easier schedule
than the Niners right now just want that
for perspective because I think that's
fair Lauren absolutely yeah the top look
it's not very difficult to imagine I've
got the full chart posted up on a sharp
football analysis calm but it's not
difficult to imagine that the teams that
have done better than expected have
played generally easier schedules and
that have failed to meet expectations
generally speaking I've played tougher
schedules but as you mentioned the
Niners have played the 10th easiest
schedule but there's a lot of teams
higher up you know up the rankings here
that have played far easier schedules
warren one of the big topics right now
around the NFL is the incredible
performance thus far of the Patriots
defense from a fan
see perspective I think they're better
than alvin kamara from a real world
perspective it seems like they have a
touchdown every game whether it's
defense or special teams people are
saying it's schedule related do you see
this defense regressing will they still
be great is it somewhere in between how
great actually is this Patriots defense
looking at the second half of the season
respective to the rest of the teams
playing defense in the NFL right now the
Patriots defense is great respective to
all-time history the Patriots defense is
very good they right now are producing
great numbers that are like all-time but
I believe once you factor in their
schedule which is about to get much more
difficult we will realize that this
defense is great currently but is not
all-time great and this is coming from a
guy who entered the season writing in my
book that I thought the Patriots defense
might carry the offense this year that's
how good I thought this Patriots defense
was the reality is they've played four
games this season that's half of their
games against teams that have bottom
three offenses right bottom three we're
talking the Dolphins the Jets and the
Redskins so they're about to start
facing teams like the Baltimore Ravens
the Philadelphia Eagles Dallas Cowboys
Houston Texans Kansas City Chiefs
they're still gonna be a good defense
this defense is not just gonna suddenly
fall off a cliff because oh my god
they're playing you know Ezekiel Elliott
right and dak Prescott but they're not
going to be producing numbers like they
were against some of these ridiculously
terrible some somewhat like all-time or
close to all-time worst offenses in the
NFL it's been beautiful to watch and I
don't want anyone to think that this is
hating or anything like that or trying
to minimize because every team has been
put in front of them
Bill Belichick Kyle van Noy and the
boogeymen have absolutely destroyed
everything that's put and put in front
of them and if there's one coach that
could keep it rolling it is Billy B at
the same time though we just want to
give the perspective that it might come
a little bit
closer to earth but right now it's in
the stratosphere and maybe it barely
enters the atmosphere you know what I
mean Warren I don't hate any team people
I [ __ ]
I view everything through the context of
are you being efficient so if you are a
team that's being inefficient and doing
dumb things then I'm not going to like
you but that's because of your process
not because of the fact that I dislike a
certain franchise or a certain city
anyway case I love their process I
absolutely love Bill Belichick one of my
favorite coaches of all time because of
how like everything he does I don't even
want to name five things because he does
25 things great but the point is it's it
would be wrong of us not to talk about
the fact that they have literally played
and that's one of the things that we do
is measure strength is scheduled better
than virtually any other outlet out
there we're measuring the schedule
worrying anticipating who they're going
to be playing and we're just stating the
facts for the people to have context
with when for when they're evaluating
the performance all right so now because
the Patriots are a team that is
undoubtedly gonna be in the in the
playoffs we're gonna break down this
strength of schedule and how they've
been doing in terms of before today
after today and whether or not they're
in the playoffs and whether or not this
should continue so the first category is
teams that have been exceeding Vegas
expectations and are currently in the
playoffs but are about to come back to
earth and I'm looking at the chart that
you can find on sharp football analysis
comm and two teams jump out to me
one the Vikings who go from the fifth
easiest schedule and drop all the way
down to the 27th and be aware they are
six and two but the one that's caught my
attention warren is the seahawks also
six and two they have the sixth easiest
schedule and they're going to the 31st
that's the second most difficult
schedule in the NFL what kind of a
drop-off could this be for the seahawks
moving forward I think it's going to be
a drop-off that's going to come as a
sudden punch to the gut for this team
primarily because of the way that they
coach their offense hmm the team whose
fence has regressed year-over-year
they're worse now than they were last
year there were slashed year than they
were the year before is a defense that
somewhat been on the decline offensively
this is a team with Pete Carroll that is
built upon the run and they've played
run defenses that actually ranked well
above ease of schedule right on average
the overall schedule of run defenses
they play about the 10th easiest they're
about to play the Tampa Bay Buccaneers
next week and over the course of the
rest of the season they're going to face
if you just want to look up like their
next five or six opponents the 40 not
beyond Tampa Bay we've got the defense
the 49ers the Eagles the Vikings and the
Rams those four teams all ranked top
half of the NFL most of them are top ten
run defenses oh it's going to be
imperative that for the Seahawks to
continue with their success they make
modifications offensively stop running
the ball so much especially early in
games don't can't afford to fall behind
because some of these teams actually do
have good offenses right if you're
playing a team that has a good run
defense but a bad offense it doesn't
really matter but if you're applying a
team that's also got a good offensive
can score on you it's going to be a
problem so Seattle is that team that is
about to face a dramatically different
schedule of opponents moving forward and
it's one that I think they're going to
have to make modifications in order to
see success moving forward as a Russell
Wilson fantasy owner do I get nervous
then I think you get excited because I
think more of this offense will have to
fall on Russell Wilson show especially
when we're talking about the schedule of
run defenses that they're about to face
I just dropped my pen cap and I'm all
out of sorts right now no I'm just
kidding okay now let's go to when you
see that by the way one more thing about
the Seahawks is it drastic enough where
you go they might be because of the
Niners success right now
the Seahawks might be fighting for a
wild-card spot is it that drastic of a
change yeah well they're still fighting
obviously have the Niners those couple
of games that they're going to play in
division will probably determine
everything I think the Seahawks are good
and
to still win some of these games but I
mean you're talking about a team that I
think we're gonna go over then later but
they could potentially their six point
favorites could potentially lose at home
to the Tampa Bay Buccaneers you don't
modify what their plans are from an
offensive side of the ball so save that
juice save that juice we'll get into
that in a second
a team that could be dealing with I mean
right now they're slated to make the
wild card and they aren't slated to win
the division so they're gonna have to do
some work against the Niners in those
two games to be able to win the division
for sure all right so now we're gonna
look at teams that have been exceeding
expectations and it's going to continue
because their schedule is actually going
to get easier
so Seattle and Minnesota or teams that
were exceeding expectations but that
schedule gets a lot harder these are
teams that are exceeding expectations
and their schedules about to get easier
and I look at the teams they're Oakland
is a team that wow they're schedule gets
easier and I think they look they've
been pretty great so far
Detroit is a team that fits that but the
one that really caught my eye Warren was
the Carolina Panthers you think the
schedule gets a lot easier huh it
definitely gets a lot easier for
Carolina this is a team that's about to
go up against defenses that are
substantially easier than what they've
played if you look at like the last five
games they've played defenses that all
ranked 14th or tougher you know they
looked terrible against the San
Francisco 49ers but they're about to go
into the part of their schedule they've
got to get through Tennessee first which
won't be easy Tennessee does have a very
good defense and then they got to play
the Green Bay Packers but after that
we're talking two games against the
Atlanta Falcons defense a game against
the Washington Redskins defense a game
against the Indianapolis Colts defense
these are all defenses and and the the
Seattle Seahawks defense who I just
mentioned their defense is not the same
as what it once was
these are games that the Carolina
Panthers offense should look better in
and especially Christian McCaffrey this
is a team really that relies a lot on
McCaffrey and you talk about who they've
just played you're talking about
the 49ers you have a great run defense
the Bucks who have the best run defense
in the NFL the
Jaguars the week before that the Houston
Texans the week before that all those
teams better against the run than the
are against the pass so now we're gonna
be into this part of the schedule where
Kyle Allen can rely a little bit more on
Christian McCaffrey on the ground that's
not to put too much of those of the
weight onto his shoulders I'm excited to
see what Carolina does over over the
second half of the season they still got
their work cut out for them to make the
postseason but the schedule is
definitely going to work in their favor
it is wild to me to think that Carroll
do it is wild to me to think that
Christian McCaffrey performs so well in
the first half of this season that
people feel obligated to put him in the
MVP discussion and they have faced the
fourth toughest schedule of opponents
and now the second half of the season
they're about to face the eighth easiest
the fact that Christian McCaffrey did
that against that schedule and now the
second half is lining up that he might
torch people even more this could end up
being historic and we don't even realize
how great he's been yet no and here but
here's the thing about Christian
McCaffrey
I still think he'll have to perform out
of this world to win MVP but it's even
it's been even more difficult than what
you're suggesting because if you just
look at the run defenses that he's faced
he has played the second most difficult
schedule of opposing run defenses so far
this year so he's done what he's done
against the number two schedule how and
since it is about to get much easier for
McCaffrey over the second half of the
year especially after the next game
that's incredible
and as a Christian McCaffrey owner I
must say I am elated okay failed to meet
expectations but we'll have easier
schedules so Warren these are teams that
failed expectations according to Vegas
thus far but there is hope on the
horizon the schedule is going to get a
lot easier not surprisingly the Jets and
dolphins qualify the questions that we
have is are they going to take advantage
of these easier schedules it's been a
fire sale that got canceled for the Jets
and Miami it's a fire sale that became
bigger file sad that we even thought but
there is one team there's one team right
now getting in fights with the media
there's one team right now that's
getting slayed by the pundits and you're
saying that a you better watch your
tongue because the schedule is about to
get a lot easier for the Cleveland
Browns break this down from your Warren
Sharpe so far the Cleveland Browns have
drastically failed to meet expectations
it has not been close but what we have
to do is take into context that they
have played the second toughest schedule
of opponents on the season they are
about to face the second easiest
schedule of opponents lack of the way so
it's pretty much what what our biggest
criticism is of Cleveland is Baker may
feel the offense what Freddie kitchens
is doing etc etc etc the reality is
Cleveland's played the number two
toughest schedule of Defense's the
number one toughest schedule of run
defenses the number four toughest
schedule of past defenses they play
tough pass rushes they're about to face
a schedule that is back-end loaded with
much more manageable defenses we're
talking about a couple games against the
Browns the Arizona but they are the
Browns who did you mean the Cincinnati
Bengals a couple games against if
Bengals game against the Dolphins games
against the Arizona Cardinals most
importantly these teams including the
Buffalo Bills who have a good defense
but what did Philly show us last week
you can run on them run on them and so
what I think is gonna happen when I'm
looking at the back half of this
schedule I just mentioned the Cleveland
Browns have played the number one most
difficult schedule of run defenses
they're about to play a schedule of run
defenses moving forward which include
bottom ten teams all over the place that
you're going to be able to run on which
is going to give Baker Mayfield relief
it's going to give him hope knotting not
having to take so much of the burden
himself that should open things up for
the passing game I'm not going to say
Freddie kitchens is doing everything
perfect I've been on the record he needs
to improve his play calling that being
said it's going to look better for the
run game that should allow them to do
more from the past
hopefully get back to his more creative
roots passing from heavier personnel
sets so if you're talking crap on Baker
Mayfield right now just be ready if in a
few weeks he's dancing in the end zone
pointing at the camera and calling you
out by name cuz it could get a little
bit dangerous for you out there just a
little warning there for more in Sharpe
I think it's a really good warning I
think it is by the way I wanted to say
it's about the Bills defense that this
is how important Harrison Phillips was
to that defensive line you know Harry
was a pretty amazing run stopper and
it'll be interesting to see how the
Bills adjust as the season goes on lucky
for them they've had the fourth easiest
schedule thus far and it becomes the
sixth easiest schedule in the second
half the bills are one a few teams that
are in that top six of easiest first and
second now Warren let's move to the
teams that have failed to meet
expectations even though their schedule
was easy and it's only going to get
worse so these are teams that are people
calling disappointing but it's still
gonna get worse of course
Atlanta's on there you mentioned that
early that's gonna be tough Los Angeles
Chargers fans I'm sorry it was supposed
to be somewhat easier it's only gonna
get tougher I know that's hard to
believe
they already fired Ken Whisenhunt who
else is going to go we'll find out but
the last one here is interesting is the
Titans the Tennessee Titans where were
they supposed to be and where are they
going according to this strength of
schedule and Vegas Warren Sharpe
well the Tennessee Titans were supposed
to be about a 500 team and that's where
they are right now so I think in
Tennessee and across the mainstream
media every school everyone's going to
believe that this team is meeting
expectations they're doing pretty well
but I take the flipside approach and I
want to look at their schedule and so
far they've played the second easiest
schedule of opponents now if they were
about to face the second easiest
schedule the rest of the way then yes
they're meeting expectations they're
doing what they need to do
against easy schedule so they should be
able to win four games the rest of the
way to hit their eighth win total but
the reality is they're about to play the
twenty sixth ranked schedule which is
one of the top ten most difficult
schedules the rest of the way through
and if you want to look at two things
where it's going to be particularly
tough for the Tennessee Titans the
Tennessee Titans defense has been what's
carried them if you look their schedule
and you look at who they've played
they've played some easy defenses so far
sorry some easy offenses the Tennessee
Titans have played the sixth easiest
schedule of opposing offenses guess who
they're going to start facing the rest
of the way forget Carolina who's a
little bit better than average in my
opinion the Kansas City Chiefs the
Indianapolis Colts the Oakland Raiders
the Houston Texans twice the New Orleans
Saints guess what that is that's one of
the toughest schedules in the NFL of
opposing offenses the rest of the way
it's not like the Chargers the Buffalo
Bills the Denver Broncos the Atlanta
Falcons the Cleveland Browns those are
the offenses that this defense has been
able to face so I think it's going to
look a lot more difficult for the
Tennessee Titans defense that's gonna
mean their offense is gonna have to
produce more points what do we know that
their offense likes to do they don't
have as much face faith in their
quarterback they want to run the
football well guess what the types of
run defenses that they're about to face
especially at the end of the schedule
the Oakland Raiders the Houston Texans
twice the New Orleans Saints those teams
are all top five literally top five run
defenses in the NFL right now so they're
not gonna have as much success running
the football their defense is going to
get more points scored on them more is
going to come down on the shoulders of
the quarterback and of the passing game
for the Tennessee Titans the rest of the
season
it's interesting I want to make this
note about the Tennessee Titans two
weeks ago they're playing the Chargers
late in the fourth quarter they're
clinging to a lead because that's what
the Titans do they establish a lead and
they barely extend it and it makes it
very afraid if you're a Titans fan and
they go for it on fourth and short with
Ryan Todd
they don't get it the Chargers drive
down in three plays they score three
touchdowns all of them are called back
somehow the Titans win Mike Vrabel is
celebrated
then last week playing the Tampa Bay
Bucs what do you know they have a lead
Jameis is turning the ball over all over
the place in his own red zone Tennessee
has the ball fourth and about five at
around the 50
what does Mike Vrabel call a fake punt
the punter I cannot believe they ran
this play gets close lined like a rock
bottom ball pops out Tampa Bay runs it
in for a touchdown the ball gets called
down Tampa Bay guess what turnover the
Titans somehow hold all the win ver able
is celebrated if there's one team that
you really want to bet against to
regress in the second half it's the team
that not only should be four and not
only is four and four and should be two
and six it's the team that Warren just
said faced the second easiest schedule
of teams and is only four and four and
should be two and six this is a team
that in my mind may finish the season
five and five and 11 they might win one
more game I was down on the Tennessee
Titans this season I thought that they
would probably fail to win nine games I
didn't think this was a team that was
going to have a winning record I thought
I was going to be a team that might
struggle one of the big reasons was
Marcus Mariota so now we got a big wild
card here because I didn't believe in
Marcus Mariota but now we've got Ryan
Tannehill in there and Tannehill is a
better passer of the football than
Mariota so how will he do how will he
assist this team in winning some games
they might end up doing a little bit
better than what I thought from the
passing efficiency perspective the fact
of the matter is as you mentioned
they're lucky to be four and four based
upon the way the games have played out
they're also lucky to be four and four
based upon their schedule if we think
both of those types of luck Harry over
the rest of the season
then this team's got a horseshoe shove
do you know where because it's probably
unlikely yeah and by the way one of
their other wins was against Atlanta so
let's just let's put all that together
let's let's put all that together I will
say this though there rookie the kid out
of mississippi state jeffrey simmons is
a baller and i'm so happy that he's back
and again this is not me hating on the
titans this is not me saying that i
don't like them no it's just looking at
facts and going this doesn't look like a
good trend what is a good trend what is
a good model you bet your ass
Edie SR Warren sharps proprietary
statistic early down success rate what
did it do last week warren oh I don't
know three and one straight up three and
one against the spread thus far since
we've started using this which is in
week six once the model had enough
information it is 10 and 2 overall it is
6 and 6 against the spread but we're
finding money line winners and the for
upsets that you felt comfortable enough
to put out really last week you said
look these are just kind of like light
upsets I don't know both of them covered
against the spread the Giants covered
against Detroit
the Chargers outright beat the Bears and
probably thanked nagy for that one so
it's four-and-oh in the upsets that
we've get you shook your head did you
want to say something about Nagy before
we move on I just think that the
Chargers really if you look at that box
score did not have a shot in that game I
don't know how the Bears ended up losing
it but you're absolutely right it's a
combination of Nagy his lack of
confidence in true Biscay his decision
that we can't get a running back to get
a couple of yards on this play to move
the ball a little bit closer a lot of it
you put it together it's a lot of
excuses and you know a 41-yard field
goal should be routine handing the ball
to your running back to gain a couple of
yards should be routine and so I don't
really buy the excuses coming out of
there well we we weren't close enough we
would the ball was on the wrong hash all
this is nonsense they need to figure out
a way to win games they're regressing
just like we thought they would this
season but but yeah that was that was a
good cover I was a little bit surprised
with the out right there alright so
again EDS are it does often show us the
biggest mismatches and oftentimes that
aligns with the biggest spreads now
we'll focus on some but then sometimes
some surprises
and so we'll focus on those two the
number one mismatch in EDS are this week
I have your notes in front of me
San Francisco over Arizona this of
course is a Thursday night football game
we are recording this Thursday afternoon
so to all the people that are hearing
this on Friday warned to use I know we
don't like kind of doing this because
who knows what's gonna happen but this
is the number one mismatch in EDS are in
week 9 yeah what I can say and we'll
keep this one short is normally on short
rest coaching edges are maximized right
like it there there
the light is shone upon them and it's
worse than what you think so if you're
at a disadvantage from a coaching
perspective and now your coach has less
time to prepare than the other guy
chances are your team is in trouble and
so I think this is a perfect case where
San Francisco massive massive coaching
edge better players I'm not saying
anything about the spread but I could
see why it opened at 7 is now sitting at
10 it's tough to lay 10 on the road on a
short week but there's no doubt about it
that if the trends have shown that when
you have less rest everything is
magnified from a mismatch perspective
the better teams end up having more
success the number 2 mismatch now I want
to say this again adsr went 3 and 1 last
week the one that lost you immediately
said I don't like this it was Buffalo
had an adsr advantage over the Eagles
you explained it to me that because
Buffalo is good on offense and defense
it makes their adsr go up and the Eagles
had struggled up to that point
defensively so it was something that
because it's your model you looked and
said oh I can see that the model is
overcompensating right now for Buffalo
which is why it's great to have you
because you know the model you gave me
this one and you said the same thing you
saw and went oh I don't like this one
you see Houston the model sees Houston
having a huge advantage over
Jacksonville and adsr
and you saw that and had pause why well
if we think about just in general back
up a little bit for what Houston is
Houston is without their number one deep
threat and Houston is dealing with
offensive line injuries and they just
lost their number one pass rusher JJ
Watt so you take into consideration both
sides of the football this team is not
necessarily from a health perspective
what earned them the ranking that
they've earned in EDS are and so from
that perspective right away I was just
like and I'll go ahead and and share it
it's still the number two mismatch on
the season from where these teams are
ranked but I don't think current form
and I actually like Jacksonville in this
spot I used him earlier in the week as a
teaser they still make for a pretty good
teaser leg given that the line is one
and a half I think Jacksonville has a
very good shot especially because this
game is in London and they're more used
to the travel and that's a big factor
going to London as you well know having
just been there so I think like Doug
Marrone I don't know if you heard his
comments but he was saying that going to
this probably isn't good for the league
but Doug Marrone said going to London
gives me diarrhea it's a big adjustment
right so you know that's probably not
the best marketing until I get people
funded no one the travel influx like him
saying that but it means that it's tough
on the body to go back and forth and you
know that better than I do having just
been there yourself yeah you know what I
do think I'll be interesting the NFL in
London
it gives me diarrhea coming up next
Jaguars Texans grab that toilet paper
roll because it's gonna get messy in
Wembley Stadium Doug Marrone standing by
with a wet wipe Doug okay thank you
thanks for letting me do that okay the
number three biggest EDS are mismatch of
week nine holy smokes
we've got ourselves an upset the Tampa
Bay Buccaneers actually have an EDS our
advantage over the Seattle Seahawks when
you saw this Warren did your
perk up 100% this matchup was one that
was definitely attractive to me even
before looking at EDS are and it's very
simple to break this game down Seattle
wants to run the football the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers are the toughest run defense
that they will have faced on the year
teams cannot run the football very
efficiently on them so teams that insist
on running the football run into two
problems
number one it's hard to get a lead
because it's hard to get your rhythm
going so it's going to be a challenge
Seattle is gonna have to do a little bit
more damage earlier in the game through
the air and they've shown that their
ability to do that to some extent but
that brings you to the second problem
which is once you have the lead for a
team that wants to run the football if
you're lucky enough to get it which you
can throw on the Bucks and Russell
Wilson's a great quarterback Seattle
should be throwing the football more
than they do so I think they could have
some success through the air here the
problem is how do you maintain that lead
and what all these running teams like to
do especially in the second half is turn
around and hand the football off to the
running back the problem is when you're
team like the 49ers you're playing the
easy run defense that's how the score
gets so ballooned out of whack is
because you can keep running the ball
and you can keep growing the score and
the score you score more points but in
this case you can't run against Tampa
Bay so you have a 13 point lead in the
third quarter and you're trying to run
and you get stopped and you have to punt
Jameis Winston has the opportunity to
pass the ball against your defense he
puts up a field goal now you got a
ten-point lead you keep trying to run
the ball but you can't because you're
playing such a good run defense so
inevitably it's hard to gain enough
separation against a really good run
defense to cover a number like this I
like the six I'll tell you for sure
problem analysis subscribers like this
is one of the reasons why you are a
subscriber because I jumped on this game
on Monday when it was six and a half and
bought to the 7 so I'm sitting there
with the 7
I feel like this line is going to
continue to trend lower it's going to go
down to five and a half and potentially
lower than that because there's no
reason why
Seattle they haven't done anything to me
to prove that they're gonna trust
Russell Wilson enough to throw the
football enough to gain enough
separation that will never be shortened
by the Tampa Bay Buccaneers not only
that they also just lost their Center
Justin Britt to an ACL so you're playing
the number one run defense in the NFL
you just lost your Center
Pete Carroll comes out and says in terms
of death work depth we're working at it
and now we know that Schottenheimer has
an obsession with not just running in
the first half but running on early
downs and if you give Jameis life and
again I'm not the biggest fan of betting
on Jameis but against that secondary the
Seahawks it could get dangerous it
really really could and let me throw one
other kind of x-factor out there not
that I trust Jane is playing in Seattle
with that crowd noise it is going to be
tough there's no doubt about it but
guess who's a coach who's had a lot of
success in Seattle
what did Bruce do in Seattle Bruce
Arians has had tremendous success as an
Arizona Cardinal with teams that
shouldn't be competitive in Seattle
being quite competitive he knows how to
coach against this defense he's very
familiar with it from his time in
Seattle it still is the same defense
they just have worse players so their
players aren't as good as when Bruce was
there and peruse has had success there
to begin with understands what it's like
to play in Seattle I think he's going to
have his team very prepared I also loved
the fact loved the fact that last week
after Jameis through a bunch of
interceptions Bruce came out and pounded
the table and said these interceptions
were not Jamie's fault I trust in my
quarterback
the receivers need to step their damn
game up and catch some of these balls
because that's not on Jameis that tells
me that Jameis is now gonna have a lot
more confidence headed into this game
then if last week after the game
Bruce was getting upset with his
quarterback after a close loss that they
should have won to the Tennessee Titans
when I had one thing about sharp
football analysis calm last week was a
perfect example of why subscribing was
beneficial when I saw that Warren
hood up the Baltimore no the Houston
Oakland over I bet it I did and what
happened was I got it at fifty and a
half you know what everybody else got it
at fifty one and a half and the number
the total was 51 and so there is an
advantage the reason that you subscribe
because we can't give you all the
information here because look I've seen
Warren put up information on his website
on Monday morning because he's trying to
get those early lines and that's the
advantage of subscribing to his website
I'm not just doing this because I'm
trying to get you guys to buy something
I'm doing this because there is an
inherent advantage of getting Warren's
information early what we do is we try
and package everything to not just teach
you but to also give you information but
realize that if he says take the over
that's not a blanket statement there is
value there is timing and there is
scheduling and that's why this is not
just it's not just a skill you know what
I mean there's there's a plan to all
this I just wanted to clarify that
Warren hope that was okay the the the
one other thing that I'll add to that is
we don't just sometimes move early we're
also sometimes moving very late so some
of the games that I like and I want to
take an over or an under I'll wait until
the line gets to the right spot if I
want to fade the market place or fade a
weather situation right like it's it's
looking like what like I'll get an alert
on my phone that Warren's putting out a
new pic at noon on Sunday and I'm like
he had his number let's do this right so
there'll be some times when we're going
early when we're going late but that's
why I'm sitting here in this bunker
staring at a bank of monitors one of
which is like literally what is this
maybe 18 inches from my eyeballs that's
got the lines all over it and it never
turns off like this TV is constantly on
is because I'm trying to figure out the
best time to move on these games the
fourth greatest EDS are mismatch is one
that I know that you don't feel
comfortable with either it is Buffalo
over Washington the reason you feel
comfortable to nine and a half points
spread it's a lot of points there is a
mismatch and as you mentioned last week
Buffalo is one of those teams that maybe
is over favored by the EDS our model
career
yeah Buffalo is and this is a big spread
Washington's coming off of a bye and a
$30 day game so extended rest extended
rest we'll see what type of new game
plan they're coming up with what type of
strategy they're coming up with as well
so yeah this is not what I love but yes
absolutely there's a big mismatch in
Buffalo's favor here
now as Warren was looking through all
the EDS are mismatches last night and I
said okay now that you're done the top
four are there any others that really
excite you and there's this funny thing
when you talk to war on the phone where
I see him pouring through notes and then
I hear oh oh and there was one I just
did the the old Kanye Bernie Mac left
Oakland over Detroit and the reason you
found that interesting was when you
looked at the spread the spread and the
mismatch didn't add up what was the
reason
yeah when you look at the Detroit Lions
versus Oakland won it one of the things
that I'm looking at here is you know a
typical home-field advantage is a
three-point line so you would expect
that Oakland if these teams were
considered equal would be a three-point
line both of them have three wins the
the Detroit Lions happen to have a tie
whereas the Oakland Raiders happen to
have a loss so one's three three and one
one's three and four but I'm looking at
this game and definitely that from an
early down perspective the Oakland
Raiders have a really solid edge here
from EDS are that's not being truly
reflected in the line now the line makes
sense when you consider what Oakland's
looked like and Oakland oh my God look
how badly they lost to the Green Bay
Packers oh my gosh they blew a lead to
the Houston Texans but there's a lot of
things that are moving in Oakland's
favor in this game primarily the fact
that this is their first home game in
what since last Thanksgiving it feels
like I mean it's been on the road since
week two their only home game was
actually in London since week two and
now we're in week 9 that is ridiculous
from week two to we know you don't play
a single game in Oakland I think that's
going to be beneficial for them I also
look at the schedule of opponents
the past defenses that they faced and
it's been brutal every single team
before the Houston Texans was top 15 in
past defense most of them
top 10 we're done on the Packers the
Bears the Vikings the Denver Broncos the
Kansas City Chiefs so now they get to go
up against the Detroit Lions which again
we'll have to see what the injury report
is darius slay may be back but he's
missed some time they traded away their
other starting safety to the seattle
seahawks and then you look at what is
detroit and this is the biggest problem
I have with Detroit and I'm gonna go on
a little tangent here okay but Detroit
is another one of these run based teams
just like we talked about with the
seattle seahawks where they want to run
the football and it doesn't matter who
they're playing or what that defense is
strengths or weaknesses are they want to
run the football last week they're
playing the New York Giants and the
Giants are team who have a dramatically
worse past defense and a really above
average slightly run defense so you want
to pass on these guys Matthew Stafford
averages 10 point 7 yards per attempt is
tearing them up through the air yet they
have almost 50% of their plays or run
plays we know they're starting running
back without their starting running back
now they're going to Oakland Oakland has
a top 10 run defense they have one of
the worst past defenses in the NFL if
there is a team with a good passing
offense like Detroit has that you might
think may not optimize their play
calling and may play into the hands a
little bit of the Oakland Raiders
it's the Detroit Lions and Matt Patricia
and the fact that they're probably going
to try to run the ball a fair amount
here and again what do we talk about
with Seattle let's say Detroit even has
a lead here at 10 or seven point lead on
the road they're viewed is the better
team by Vegas that's why they're not
catching three points let's say they
have a slight lead here
how are they gonna salt it away by
running the football against a really
good run defense probably unlikely
without their number one running back
and if they don't choose to pass the
football here it's great opportunity for
Derek Carr to get back into this game
against potentially a beat-up secondary
oh man I this is one of the better
slates of games I've seen in terms of
feeling comfortable about the spreads
like do you feel that too
I there's been like four weeks in a row
where I did not really like the card and
it's it's hard to cards break certain
ways you feel certain ways about team's
matchups etc and last week I kind of
started liking that card
it was the bet it was the my favorite
card probably the last month and it
showed in the results in the records
this week I liked the card as well I
think there's some good betting
opportunities on the board here for us
alright so let's get into less of a
betting this this I feel like helps more
daily fantasy and also fantasy in
general and and solo performances so UI
strength of schedule mismatches compared
to what a team has faced and what
they're facing this week we do pass we
do run we do defense and I want to show
you that it's been working two weeks ago
the easiest pass off and shift was
Gardner Minshew surprise surprise
he had his over Jacksonville wins by 10
last week the easiest past shift was
Matt Stafford than Detroit Lions and
what do you know last week Matt Stafford
goes 342 yards three touchdowns one
interception
it was his highest passer rating of the
season it was his highest completion
percentage of the season 78%
I mean Drew Brees and Sam Bradford are
getting jealous at 78% it was the
highest yards per attempt of the season
by by 2 by 2 yards 10 point 6 9 the
second highest was 8 point 5 6 so it's
gonna jump fellas the highest strength
of schedule change in mismatch this week
the number one was the Jets Sam darn
'old against the Miami Dolphins but we
looked at that and we talked on the
phone and we said I don't know about
Adam GaSe I don't know about this
offense I don't know how they're feeling
after this fire sale so I said ok Warren
let's move to number two and the number
two biggest mismatch is the Dallas
Cowboys against the New York Giants so
all my ears perk up when I go could this
be a big dak
I think it could be a big dak week as
long as the weather is fine in New York
they're playing on the road it's a
Monday Night Football game we know
Dallas wants to run the football they'll
eventually if they've got to lead their
seven-point Road favorites will end the
game probably running the football if
they if they're doing well here so it's
not going to be the case where they're
trailing enough to throw the football a
lot
however we look at the Giants they're a
great team to attack with the pass we
just attacked them with Matthew Stafford
last week if you look at what Dax faced
over the last month of the season with
the games he's played granted they have
it a bye week last week they played the
Saints the 11th best pass defense the
Green Bay Packers v sorry the 8th best
pass defense the Jets who have a
surprisingly decent pass defense and the
Philadelphia Eagles whose past defense
was being able to take advantage of dak
had a really good game they're also able
to run the football a little bit and
they scored 37 points at home we haven't
seen him since that game and I think now
that Amari is fully healthy their
tackles are fully healthy they're going
to be able to attack the New York Giants
defense through the air and dak should
have a better game than probably many
people are expecting him to have that's
awesome
easiest run shift last week Warren Sharp
said hey it's the Rams in London taking
on the Bengals and one of the rams do
they had they had it's interesting it
was their whole offense was better they
had their best third down conversion
rate of the season they had their
highest average game per pass which is
very interesting because the Rams are a
team that uses play-action so they were
able to have success with the run early
and think about it all the Cooper Cup
fantasy owners out there are like oh
yeah I saw that impact they had 12
compared to 8.5 so it was the easiest
shift in the run but because the Rams
are a play-action team it actually
really helped them in the past and the
biggest strength of schedule change easy
for the run is actually the Vikings this
week Dalvin cook against the Kansas City
Chiefs what are you thinking here Warren
Davin's played the 14th toughest
schedule of run D
over the last month and really if you
look at over the course of the full
season he's played so many difficult top
ten run defenses this year now he gets
to go up against the easiest run defense
he will face over the entire year the
Kansas City Chiefs not just previous but
also in the future he will not get a
better team to run the football against
than the Kansas City Chiefs Kansas City
Chiefs obviously we love Andy Reed the
creativity the eye brings to the offense
they are most likely going to be going
with Matt Moore a backup quarterback
that hasn't been officially announced as
of yet which is why there's no line on
this game but I'm expecting if Matt
Moore is the quarterback that there's
going to be opportunities with Minnesota
in the lead a little bit to run the
football here and Dalvin cook has been
producing from a fantasy perspective
he's doing it through the air and on the
ground you could throw the football to
him he can gain chunk yards on the
ground as well and I'm sure everybody
who has them in fantasy has been really
happy with what he's been delivering to
your roster that's going to get
potentially a lot better in this game
against the Chiefs I want to say this
too from the Chiefs injury perspective
Frank Clark and Alex Okafor did not
practice on Wednesday Chris Jones though
limited practice with that groin injury
and I say it every week how important
Chris Jones is to that run defense you
do not have a defensive tackle that gets
17 18 sacks last year and then never
bring them up in the national media when
the Chiefs defense is struggling
don't call him a top three defensive
lineman and then when he goes down be
like but I don't know what's going on
with the team's defense I don't get it
I also want to say that Patrick mahomes
is feeling really good right now I don't
know if they're gonna rush him back
against this defense but I want everyone
to know that mahomes is feeling good and
he's ready to go and they're kind of
just there the one saying Pat slow the
[ __ ] down okay I just want to get that
out there
easiest defensive shift last week week
eight Warren said it was the Lions
facing the Giants and this is the one
that I thought oh no Warren's little
strength of schedule thing here
backfired everyone told me about how
Daniel Jones threw four touchdowns well
guess what I looked it was the fewest
net yards allowed for the Lions this
season it was the fewest yards per play
that the Lions have allowed this season
it was the first game all season in
which the Lions allowed under a hundred
yards rushing
they allowed 80 so it was like the
lowest amount of rushing yards by a mile
it was also the fewest game per rush but
the Lions were and the Giants excuse me
you were able to hit a few deep balls to
Darius Leighton that were able to make
it look like the Lions offense was great
but that's football man smoke and
mirrors and a bunch of illusions it's
David Blaine david copperfield and we're
just sitting here losing money to Vegas
week nine who has who has faced the
toughest slate of offenses that now face
the biggest let me try that again which
team is facing and easier offense and
they faced all year Warren Sharpe from
the defensive perspective it is
definitely by far the Cleveland Browns
the Cleveland Browns defense is going to
look a lot better this week remember
Cleveland just got both their starting
quarterbacks back right against the New
England Patriots and that was the New
England Patriots the game was in the
rain they looked okay this week they're
going to be playing the Denver Broncos I
know it's in Denver but guess what
Cleveland's played over the last month
plus of the season they've played the
Rams offense the Ravens often is very
difficult to prepare for the San
Francisco 49ers offense the Seattle
Seahawks offense and the New England
Patriots often I mean we're talking
about top 15 top ten
offenses around the league with creative
play callers with decent quarterbacks
that's the list right you're talking
about Tom Brady and Russell Wilson and
Lamar Jackson and Jimmy Garoppolo and
obviously we're gonna throw the Rams in
there because of sharp Bay I don't love
Jared Goff but that's besides the point
now they're going up against
Brandon Allen a backup of a backup
basically quarterback in Denver
I think the Browns defense should look a
lot better this week
I what's really great is is before I we
had this conversation
I dropped Tennessee's defense and I
picked up Cleveland's and that it's I
mean it was the perfect switch like I
feel like it's amazing but I look at
Cleveland already because we're getting
to the point of the show where I'm kind
of formulating all of my my Westgate
super contests you know angry Baker
Mayfield yelling at the media I feel
like he plays better when he's angry
it's like what happened against
Baltimore against a Denver team or they
have a quarterback that called out
really the cojones of the coaching staff
by saying I'm Joe Flacco I averaged less
than five yards per completion and I
wanted to go for it on fourth and five
and now this Denver team they lose a
heartbreaking game they come home and
they have Brandon Allen playing who I
mean I don't think 99% of our listeners
know where Brandon Allen went to college
and to me the the issue for the Browns
that the Browns defense really was not
that bad against New England you know I
watched a defensive touchdown for the
New England Patriots and I watched Baker
Mayfield shovel a ball into the chest of
a defensive lineman you know there was a
lot of bad turnovers in that game that
set up short fields the Cleveland Browns
defense look they held the Rams 20
points you know like it's been a lot of
this offense setting up this defense and
miles Garrett against a very rough
Denver Broncos offensive line and I
believe JaJuan James is already out it
could be a beautiful beautiful day for
the Browns defense cannot agree more
with everything that you just said there
there's no reason that the Cleveland
Browns should not have covered that game
against the New England Patriots last
week
anybody who bet on the Browns just
remember not all bets are gonna play out
and that's why you have to take
everything into context you should have
covered that game I was not on the
Browns I did not have a side in that
game whatsoever but that was a game that
you should have likely won
I'm not opining on the side this week
but I will simply say exactly as you
said it's a very tough matchup and for
those of you that want to argue that all
well Joe Flacco hasn't been good anyways
it's Joe Flacco so replacing him can
be that much worse who knows maybe
you're right but one of the things that
we said going into when Denver played
the Chargers a couple of weeks ago and
pulled the outright upset is that Joe
Flacco was having one of his best years
of his career from a you know and that
just tells you a little bit about Joe
Flacco but he was having a very good
year from a yards per attempt from a
completion rate from a touchdown the
interception perspective in Denver this
past season so no he has not been a very
good quarterback no he was especially
not good against the Indianapolis Colts
no he probably should not have called
called out his coaching staff publicly
like that could any team be more
aggressive on fourth downs yes league
wide most teams probably should be a
little bit more aggressive probably
wasn't the right time to do it and I'm
worried about his backup here in this
game very funny I looked the Cleveland
Denver over/under the total was 43 when
it opened and it's already been bet down
to 39 that's a four point drop so were
you one of the people that jumped on
that early like a genius I did not I did
not take the under here on but it
definitely the problem is it was pulled
off the board a little bit once Joe flat
right out and then it got reposted at a
lower number definitely money has
continued to come in on the under here
though for good reason I mean Denver
does have a very good defense as well
all right so let's continue to update
how teams are performing after the bye
weeks thus far against the spread teams
off of a bye are four and eight against
the spread teams that are playing at
home after a bye after the Pittsburgh
Steelers beat the Dolphins but did not
cover it falls to three and three
against the spread teams playing on a
road after a bye there were three
instances in week 8 the Panthers the
Browns and the Bucs all didn't cover so
teams playing on the road after a bye
are one in five against the spread but
the big thing is betting against teams
after a buy is something we've talked
about and apparently our little away
home thing is not holding up and I don't
really want to get involved there are
two teams coming off two off a buy one
Monday Night Football the Dallas Cowboys
traveling to the New York Giants I want
to say two things that are interesting
to me remember last year coming off of a
bye I would argue the most embarrassing
game of the Dallas Cowboys season a
14-point loss to Marcus Mariota and the
Tennessee Titans also an update that I
got on the BR app two Cowboys late to a
meeting Jason Garrett sends Antoine
Woods and Tristan Hale home for being
late to a meeting this Thursday so what
do you know
the Cowboys sleep and in late didn't
come out great after the bye last week
now they're playing Monday Night
Football it is against the Giants I
don't like betting on Daniel Jones
against Michael Bennett and DeMarcus
Lawrence I'm not gonna touch that game
at all I'm just saying hey they're
coming off of a bye does that spark
anything for you or not not particularly
didn't think it would okay the other t
he did use there anything else you want
to say there no III think you covered it
well the by I think a lot of what
happens on the by is coaching related I
will say that when we look at the trends
over the last five years since the CBA
those are strong trends over a number of
years when we're talking about a small
sample size of like five six games for a
road off of by this year we have to
consider the sample size some of the
teams that are involved in those games
so again I am never one to say well this
is what this one single angle says so
I'm gonna bet the game because of just
this angle I never never ever do that
it's something taking consideration the
other team coming off of a buy leads us
perfectly into the game of the week we
are not breaking down the ones the four
o'clock I made sure that we touched on
damn near every frickin game in every
single segment that we've done because
in my mind there's one game it is Sunday
Night Football and if you're not sitting
down at a television you're being wrong
in this
the Baltimore Ravens coming off of a bye
at home taking on Bill Belichick and the
New England Patriots Westgate has it as
New England favored by three it casinos
across the country the line has jumped
to three and a half it opened at four
and a half
Warren sharp we've been waiting for it
the New England Patriots finally facing
a good team the Baltimore Ravens finally
facing a defense that may show the
blueprint on how to contain Lamar
Jackson John Harbaugh with a bye for
extra preparation Warren where would you
like to start I would like to start with
Lamar versus the Patriots defense then
let's do that
exactly as you said in that intro what
is Bill Belichick gonna do to try to
stop Lamar and could that be the
blueprint for what other teams start
using I love that term the blueprint
because I not just do as a jay-z album
but it's also very good I think from
when we're talking about people copy off
of Bill Belichick left and right and so
I'm very fast he doesn't have extra time
to prepare for this game but you could
guarantee ever since he saw Lamar
Jackson running around the field last
season knowing that he was gonna have to
play Lamar this year but he started
thinking about what he's gonna do when
it comes to week nine and what he's
going to do once that schedule got
announced on Sunday Night Football to
try to stop Lamar Jackson in Baltimore
here's a tough thing though here's a
tough thing last week he was at home he
was a big favorite against the worst
team perspectively the Cleveland Browns
it's raining do you really have to do a
whole lot against that passing offense a
Baker may feel they haven't been all
that good this year right and he
struggled to stop Nick Chubb Nick Chubb
was tearing through that team like a hot
knife through butter frequently and they
struggled to stop the run game I don't
think they can have or afford to utilize
that same game plan against Lamar
Jackson they can't give up all these
rushing yards to the Ravens on the
ground and expect to win this game so
their main priority I mean obviously
right
make Lamar a passer do what the charters
did last year in the post season which
is get up to a big lead fourth forced
Lamar to drop back in 11 personnel
consistently and throw the football down
the field now the good part for
Baltimore is you do get Marquis Brown
back so Josh right because you haven't
had him for weeks okay so he's back your
tight ends are healthy you're good to go
from a receiver perspective I also seem
to remember and we're gonna stick on
this side of the ball cuz we're gonna
break this game down a lot of deep Adam
I seem to remember the Baltimore Ravens
making a comment after they beat the
Miami Dolphins week one to the effect of
do you guys have no idea what we've got
in the rest of our playbook because we
don't even need to use it on these
chumps we've got so much more back here
that we've got ready to unleash and
we're just gonna keep it under wraps and
guess what they've had a bye week who
knows what this creative offense is
going to try to pull out and shock Bill
Belichick with because let's not forget
Bill Belichick knew that he was facing
these guys week nine Sunday night in
Baltimore but Baltimore knew that they
were gonna have two weeks to prepare for
Bill Belichick defense and they've known
this all offseason so air was a prop bet
to bet on over trick plays this is the
game like if there was like I would set
the line at over/under two and a half
trick plays in this game and it might
there might be five but this is the game
where this is the game where Belichick
has lined up tight ends at tackle after
watching Alabama against Baltimore bill
a check has thrown wide receiver passes
against Baltimore Baltimore's throw and
wide receiver passes against New England
this is the playbook Bowl this is the
two teams that not only are they trying
to win they're trying to get done the
game and have the other team walking up
to the refs and going that's illegal and
they get to waive it and go I read it in
the playbook pal the Harbaugh Belichick
game plan Bowl is one of the best games
every year and because the Ravens had an
extra week to just diagram we could see
some wild stuff Warren
very excited I'm super excited too and
if you look at the games that the New
England Patriots have struggled with
opponents they've only played three
teams that ranked twelfth were better
running the football the Baltimore
Ravens are one of the three the other
two were the Buffalo Bills and the
Cleveland Browns Buffalo kept that game
super tight that was a very
back-and-forth game and Cleveland again
they lost the game by 14 that game
should have been much closer the way
that it finished so I think this game is
going to be tight start to finish you're
a hundred percent on point with the
thought that Baltimore has got some
trick plays worked up their sleeve do
you remember the game one of my
favorites was they lined up next to the
Center at the guard position they lined
up a tight end who was a little bit back
off of the line of scrimmage and after
the snap they ran him out in a pattern
to convert a first down against the
Pittsburgh Steelers this is a type of
stuff that John Harbaugh is thinking of
remember John Harbaugh was a special
teams coach special teams coaches are
very creative with trick plays generally
when they move to a better role within
an organization which he obviously did
he came from Philly as special teams guy
he's a head coach of the Baltimore
Ravens they come up with things they
like to insert them in the games to
gains those edges so on that side of the
football I can't wait to see the style
and the strategy that Belichick utilizes
will he force them are to stay in the
pocket will the Mar break contain in it
all and will Lamar be able to throw the
football down the field that's is why
it's vital that Baltimore does not fall
behind early because we don't want
Baltimore to be in a situation where
they have to use three wides play-action
doesn't work right and that's just Lamar
throwing the football down the field as
long as and I don't think they will the
only way I think they fall behind early
is exactly what happened to Cleveland
you can't turn the ball over know how
they lost to the Chargers in that
playoff game at home they turn the ball
over Lamar put it on the carpet defense
aggressively attacked him sacked in
fumble recovered put up some early
points they can't have that happen if
they survive that first 20 minutes
they'll be in good shape and what
quite a battle on our hands I also I
also love that Belichick has never faced
Lamar before because the first time
Belichick faces somebody you see the
complete study he's done but also it's
an advantage when Belichick has faced
you already he really knows you and now
it's not just finding the pressure point
it's pressing down as hard as he can the
first time he faced Patrick mahomes it
was everyone the line of scrimmage
everyone drop out the problem is is the
Ravens are a power running team and if
everybody falls back and you're moving
backwards and you got Ronnie Stanley and
all those guys coming right in your face
for a power run it could be interesting
other side of the ball has been the
Achilles heel of both teams the Patriots
and Tom Brady's offense have not looked
great this year
we've seen more Soni Michele that I
think people have expected Josh Gordon's
not on the team Julian Edelman is on the
injury report limited practice on
Wednesday but talk about the health
coming back for the Baltimore Ravens
Earl Thomas the only player on the
Ravens that did not practice on
Wednesday but you know who practiced in
a limited capacity Jimmy Smith don't
know if he's playing but Harbaugh did
come out to say that he is quote on
track to return and we've said this if
their secondary is Humphrey Peters and
Jimmy Smith this could be an entirely
new Baltimore Ravens defense how do you
see this side of the ball flowing out
Lauren it's gonna be another big
question mark because as you mentioned
the weakness of Baltimore has been their
defense their ability to get pressure
their ability to cover on the back end
when that pressure is not there but now
they've got a much upgraded secondary
Humphrey he's been playing really strong
they made the trade for Marcus Peters
they just got him he's had the bye week
now to get further integrated and we
know the Ravens splits with and without
Jimmy Smith are massive so that's
several new stud guys in the secondary
that are ready for the Patriots but this
isn't the Patriots of old who had an
explosive passing attack and that was
the real weapon with Gronk and all these
receivers and so many different things
they do this is a passing attack that
ranks outside the top ten in
efficiency and they played the second
easiest schedule of opposing past
defenses so far this season this is not
the same passing offense they're also
without Josh Gordon who they had at some
points earlier in the season so I'm
really interested to see what ends up
happening when New England has the ball
what their strategy is because again
their focus holistically needs to be to
get a lead so Lamar has to throw the
football that's the way that they can
help their defense is is not by
controlling the ball and just slowly
clicking off time and kicking a field
goal it's by jumping out to a multi
scorer lead a two score lead a nine
point lead a ten point lead a 13 point
lead but they're not really built right
now to explosively jump out on people
and Baltimore's getting healthier in the
secondary and on the back half so if you
want to look at the teams that Baltimore
is played with good offenses they've
played two really good offenses so far
this year they played the Kansas City
Chiefs in Kansas City week three tore
him up super close game but Kansas City
did have success throwing the football
on them and moving the ball on them but
that was a great game it was our game to
be honest Lamar Jackson made three plays
that were like Air Bud and so it was a
close game but like Kansas City probably
should have won that game by 25 if I'm
being honest it definitely they
definitely could have for sure yeah some
of those passes were just like balls in
total lock put and then the Seattle game
was the next team that they played where
they actually had Marcus Peters in the
secondary and they held Seattle at home
to only 16 points now let's not make a
mistake Bill Belichick and this offense
is going to be a lot better scheme than
strategized than what the Seahawks
offense was last you know the last game
that the Baltimore Ravens played two
weeks ago but I'm fascinated to see the
X's and O's matchups on this side of the
ball usually one of the things that I
notice about Bill Belichick when he
plays a really good team that he
respects a lot like he really respects I
heard you know in the press conference
about how much he respects Baltimore he
respects Harbaugh you know this
Baltimore's near Annapolis right that's
a
Navy town that's where Bill Belichick
his background is naval and this this is
he has a lot of respect for that city
the way they built that team he had a
lot of respect for their old GM Ozzie
Newsome and so he tends to play teams
that he has a lot more respect a little
bit differently like more carefully more
strategically where as teams that he
doesn't really respect like the
Pittsburgh Steelers he just like tricks
them and laughs and throws on him all
the time teams like the Jets he doesn't
care about he'll do all types of things
but teams he respect he tends to come
out a little bit more cautiously so I'm
interested to see I think this game is
like I said gonna be super tight
throughout and what's amazing to me is
you add the third level the game special
teams
the Patriots just cut their kicker Mike
Nugent and signed Nick Foulke and the
Ravens have arguably the greatest kicker
of all time in Justin Tucker and we
talked about all this it sounds like the
Ravens may have an advantage on offense
sounds like the Ravens may have an
advantage on defense
sounds like the Ravens may have an
advantage on special teams and I sit
before you today going I still wouldn't
bet them because Bill Belichick is the
dark Sith Lord that I've never seen
really lose and like that's why this
game is amazing to me because I think
it's gonna be so fun to watch because I
do think the Ravens have a lot of
advantages that other teams have not had
over the Patriots all year but it's
still Bill Belichick it's still Tom
Brady and it's still the boogeyman like
what would you advise people after they
just heard us wax poetic about the
Ravens for 15 minutes
how would do you do you calm their
excitement to run to the window or do
you embolden it well I also want to
share a couple of interesting trends
here one of which I was just looking up
on the fly we've got the Patriots coming
off of a bye I'm sorry the Ravens Ravens
I we've got the Patriots heading into a
bye okay John Harbaugh is one of the
best coaches in the NFL coming out of a
bi he's something like nine and two 80s
he's ridiculous but a team that is
really good heading into a bye okay is
the New England Patriots they are since
2002 they're 20
and for when they're heading into a by
21 and for I want to say like your last
[ __ ] if I go back let me just sorry I'm
doing this on the fly but if I go back
on the fly just a 2009 just a 2009
before heading into an extra week
this team is 14 and 1 now that does
include playoff games when they're
heading into when they're playing we 20
and don't have a game next week so if I
get rid of playoff games the New England
Patriots are 9 and 1 straight up
8 and 2 80s when they have a buy the
next week during the regular season very
good when they're about to head into a
bye usually very focused so you've got
Harbach coming out of a buy rate 80s
you've got Belichick heading into a buy
great 80s you've got the matchups on
both sides of the ball you've got
everything we talked about of the gist
the intrigue the overall mystique of
what is Bill Belichick gonna do against
Lamar Jackson such a unique quarterback
you're such a defensive mind I have not
bet anything on this game I will tell
the 33% what's been interesting to me
more than anything about this game is
the total opened at 46 46 and a half
took a bunch of under money dropped it
all the way down to 44 and has since
taking some over money and now it's back
to 45 some 45 and a half so a couple of
groups very drastic positions and
they're not just you know small
positions where I will put a couple of
grand on this they're banging the hell
out of the board getting this thing drop
in multiple points towards the under and
then a point half back towards the over
even early in the week it doesn't take a
few thousand bucks to do something like
that it takes a little bit more of a
concerted effort with deeper pockets so
the total is intriguing the side
obviously is dropping the Ravens are
clearly the sharp side of this game
right I just can't wait for it in terms
of the total are you gonna research that
all over the next few days and see if
there's still value there or have you
already done that I've looked at it I'm
trying to see where the market is going
to go from here I want to
if the guys who were betting the under
are gonna take another piece of it if
they do that probably means that it's
extremely sharp because they got some at
46 and now they don't want more yeah
when the limits are higher then they
come back in and buy more towards the
under we saw the game again last week
where Cleveland Baltimore that game
should have been a surefire under with
ease it end up seeing a lot of points
scored in the first half it actually
went over the first half total but
that's because of defensive mistakes and
things of that nature
defensive scores by the Patriots you
can't say those things definitely won't
happen because they've been continuing
to happen all season long it's hard to
handicap the fact that oh you're
definitely getting seven points from the
Patriots defense here so I'm gonna keep
researching that one either coming yeah
and again Warren puts his final picks on
sharp football analysis calm you can
subscribe he's had plenty of access
codes and stuff for you guys to get
packages in the past so hopefully you've
already bought if not just check it out
there's good contents there's good
content it's it's one of my mainstays on
Monday morning the the the article that
you put out of like the ten nuggets the
article that you put out today that's
available to really anybody evaluating
team performance of the seasons midway
point is very extensive and if you enjoy
reading about every team in the NFL
which is exhausting to write Warren does
it so it's good content it's not just
picks but I need to enter my pace with
crack so let us get crack on the phone
the number one proxy in the history of
the world the number one fedora we're in
the history of the world and the number
one analysis of Italian sauce in the
history of the world you would agree
with all that right Warren definitely
definitely especially the fedora
oh it's Samuel Jackson and it's Bill
Kraken burger and that's really it
hey guy she here that war did you hear
that crack we were saying about how it's
you in Samuel Jackson the two best
Fedora wearers in the history of the
world
oh yeah I love them I love that I got 13
of them by the way I just wear the black
and the blue one that's about it you
don't care that it's unlucky number 13
like do we need to ship you an extra one
to get
you off of that number 13 it's not
believable actually the number 13 has
been very lucky for me in my life it's
kind of weird you know you don't want to
depend on luck for things but the
combinations of ones and threes and
especially three has been a lucky number
for me I don't know why well a wise man
I believe it was Socrates once told me
that 1 & 3 are very important numbers in
gambling I think it was Socrates oh
there you go all right so I actually
have not said the five ways that I'm
leaning yet - Warren so he's gonna see
this for the first time to crack and
then I'm gonna get your pick on the game
of the week you ready to go sure okay
these are some these are subject to
change
I like I like Oakland - two and a half
against Detroit
I like Tampa Bay plus six at Seattle I
like Indy - one in Pittsburgh
I like Jacksonville plus one against
Houston and I think I'm gonna get a
little Randy and take Cleveland - three
in Denver do you hate any of those are
like any of those I would love the Bucs
in my best play so the bucks plus six
verse Seattle it sticks on the pool The
Sharper sports books Westgate just went
to five out here they just got hit on
that OB the place is offshore six dog 20
I think the points there is good you
know bucks the Bucs 155 240 I've every
was a ridiculous score over the Rams in
and at the Rams on the road and then
they lost three in a row
so I mean while their seasons actually
depending on this maybe I think they're
I'm not sure I think there's one five so
this is a key game for them I know
they're going into Seattle but I like
them this week also I agree with you
that's warm up well my place my other
play I matched you with Cleveland so to
play by Matthew I think Cleveland - the
threes good line value actually three
and a half and three - the quarters out
there so three on the pool it's great
line value and I agree with that one the
other ones I don't have an opinion on
Jacksonville I could see it though for
sure but see you what
did you say Colts versus dealers yeah I
just i watch the steelers and i was like
they look like [ __ ] yeah the miami could
have won that game outright by the way
so Warren had had Steelers first half
plus seven and a half that right Warren
um yeah the Dolphins plus seven and a
half yeah sorry Dolphins right yet
Dolphins plus seven in that first half
the dog there so I mean we were rooting
for Miami first half but I could have
swore Miami for the game was it was you
know that was in jeopardy at the end but
it shouldn't have been so this other
dolphins were anyway this is a bet
against the Steelers what I'm saying
they didn't look good with the
quarterback there and I a hundred
percent would not be taking Steelers
there so the Colts there I I listen I
also I think the Bears have been a major
disappointment business you know this
season sure then again so of the Eagles
the Eagles have been you know back and
forth I know they they lost two weeks
ago there's a bad loss to Dallas and
they go on B feet of Buffalo squad about
you know the club close supposed to be a
close game it was a blowout so I think
this is a big game for the Bears though
think this is a this is like a must-win
for them to the so I think they're gonna
play puff paint home dog this week I've
seen unusual but a lot of home dogs and
I'm sure we're gonna get into the
biggest game on the card here well yes
the Patriots right yes all right so
here's my question for you crack because
I think really what I've learned about
you is your specialty is not just
reading the market but also kind of
seeing where value can kind of perk up
and me more we're just talking about how
the the total has been fluctuating for
Ravens Patriots the line is starting to
have some movements so I'm not really
asking for what your bet is
I'm curious how are you reading how the
Sharps and the squares are playing
Baltimore New England and how do you
foresee that kind of adjusting over
Friday Saturday and into Sunday all the
wise guys that are by the way it's a
fine time Sunday night game New
England's finally playing a theme that
the a good team after having a pretty
fairly easy schedule or a first-date
game first
for weekend another playing a part of
their toughest contest obviously is
going to be the Ravens and also all the
sharp guys are the ones that are betting
the NFL though will be betting Baltimore
if they haven't already just got the lay
on the line actually was a four for a
second out there when it opened down to
three and a half three and a half dogs
money and matter of fact there's some
fries actually here at the South Point
it's actually a three so I mean this
contest is also a three yeah look I said
the wise guys are going to be on the dog
there and I'll just tell you though that
the exact a combination of Brady
belcheck just is a it's something that
comes on oddly comes across that every
every quarter of a century so it's three
in the contest I would not believe it or
not I would not be going with the sharp
wise guy side the Baltimore I think
maybe knowing one side minus the three
in the caucus is a good pick I will
probably be picking that in my contest
actually going against the move and I
think as it comes more towards game time
yeah people are gonna realize that
people want to bet they won't they want
they want a bet both even people in
Vegas even the squares are going to be
on Baltimore in this game so which is
unusual so again I actually in the
contrary and I'm gonna say that they're
in one - let's breathe - good good play
in the pool yeah I'm staying away from
it all together I think it's a game that
I'm so excited to watch and maybe I'm
gonna do some in-game betting if I start
seeing like a like if Baltimore starts
getting a lot of traction on the run and
New England starts on cork and some
trick plays but right now I think it's a
game I don't want to bet I just kind of
want to watch it but knowing me I'm
gonna chase Sunday night's crack you are
the man and watch
I don't watch many games but I don't
watch that game what you're right I'm
watching that game good I'll text you on
Friday dude you're the man and we need
to link up soon thank you're the man as
always you can download the crack wins
app crack Matthew and the boys have put
it together it's in my opinion a really
beautiful interface it's easy to get the
lines on a mobile app if you want to and
of course crack gives out one pick a
week and then if you subscribe and pay
he will give you many more
and it's crack so and I and crackin
burger he is the man he's a great guy
and we support him
Warren anything else that you either
heard from my pics what Warren said that
you'd like to talk about before we get
out of here I do want to tell you it
doesn't relate to the pics but I didn't
know the record beforehand and you asked
me about it
I feel I want to fill it in Bruce Arians
as a Cardinals head coach four and one
straight up and against the spread in
Seattle Wow he they're dogs
all four of those games that he won
outright a ten point dog he won outright
a three point dog he went out right an
eight point dog two different times and
he won those games out right in Seattle
holy crap
and is a perfect way to lead with an
exclamation point is hey not only is
this team Tampa Bay favored and EDS are
but there's a coaching possible
advantage here with a trend when those
two things align Wow uh we're gonna need
that music because Warren needs to go
out and be the legend that he is he's
going as a wolf that a a grand MA
tonight cuz he's a baller Warren you're
the man I love you for Warren I am the
lef koe man to the 33% out there follow
Warren on Twitter at sharp football
check out his website at sharp football
analysis it is a subscription that I
promise you is worth it and thank you as
always for downloading or watching the
Left Coast show on Fridays appreciate
y'all keep kicking ass good luck at the
window holla at you later
[Music]